حزمه جديده من العقوبات الاوروبيه على
روسيا من المقرر ان يعلن عنها الاتحاد
قريبا وتستهدف في جانب كبير منها شركات
صينيه دبلوماسيون قالوا انه تم تحديث
ثماني شركات صينيه يعتقد انها قدمت لموسكو
اجهزه الكترونيه بما في ذلك اشبه الموصلات
ويمكن استخدامها لاغراض عسكريه احدى تلك
الشركات هي كينج التي سبق ان اتهمتها
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بتوفير الرقائق
الكترونيه دقيقه لروسيا تمكنها من
استغلالها في انظمه توجيه صواريخ كروز ليس
فقط الصواريخ شركه اخرى هي ايجا باسيف
كلينكس المسجله في هونغ كونج تحدث تقرير
بريطاني عن انها ما زالت منتجاتها تدخل في
تصنيع مسيارات اورلان عشره الروسيه ايضا
من بين الشركات الصينيه من يرسل منتجاته
مباشره الى موسكو او يشتري منتجات غربيه
كوسيط ثم هذه المنتجات مزدوجه لاستخدام
الى روسيا وفي محاوله اوروبيه لسد الثغرات
تقترح حزمه العقوبات وضع نظام لحظر تصدير
بعض المنتجات الى دول خارج الاتحاد
الاوروبي او شركات يعتقد انها تساعد روسيا
في التحايل على القيود الغربيه الانباء عن
نيه فرد بروكسل لعقوبات على بكين دفع كبار
المسؤولين الصينيين الى التلويح بالرد
بقوه على العقوبات الاوروبيه التحذير جاء
من وزير الخارجي الصيني في برلين خلال
لقائه مع نظيرته الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
نحن لا نزود البلدان التي تمر بازمات
باسلحه هذا قانوننا في الصين وعندما نصدر
منتجات باستخدام مزدوج لدينا ايضا قوانين
لتنظيم تلك الحالات هناك تعاون بين شركات
الصين وروسيا ولا يجب زعزعه هذا التبادل
الطبيعي نعارض بشده قيام بعض الدول وفق
قوانينها المحليه بفرض عقوبات احاديه
الجانب ضد الصين او اي دوله اخرى واذا كان
الامر كذلك فسنرد ايضا بشكل صارم وحاد
وسندافع عن المصالح القانونيه والمشروع
لبلدنا وشركاتنا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات